foreign
[Music]
you're a butterfly fluttering around
pursuing a butterfly's whims then you
wake up but how do you know you're not
dreaming now the answer might seem
obvious but it's actually very difficult
to explain how definitively you know
you're awake
so difficult in fact that it is puzzled
philosophers since ancient times in the
butterfly scenario the ancient Chinese
philosopher juanza surfaced a mystifying
possibility if we can dream of being an
entirely different creature who's to say
we're not actually a different creature
dreaming of Being Human bizarre things
happen in dreams you fly or conjure an
all-you-can-eat dessert Buffet out of
thin air or get chased by witches
through the halls of your Elementary
School which suddenly looks a lot like
Paris but the strange things that happen
in dreams don't seem strange at the time
so how do you know you're not in a dream
right now that will seem very strange
after you wake up
well it is possible to notice the
strangeness of a dream while you're
dreaming lucid dreamers know they're
Dreaming by definition if you were
having a lucid dream you would know it
but all that proves is that you're not
having a lucid dream it doesn't prove
you're awake
there has to be a Surefire test
something that never or only happens
when you're awake something that never
or only happens in a dream wake up nope
that isn't it you can wake up in a dream
pinch yourself if it hurts aren't you
really awake try to read or write
something run around the room does your
pace seem normal or suspiciously slow
suspiciously fast can't tell try to
remember the last time you ran
actually that brings us to an even
better test from the 17th century French
philosopher Renee Descartes he pointed
out that in our memories dreams are
disconnected the events of a dream don't
fit into the chain of events in our
waking lives
this seems Rock Solid doesn't it you
couldn't possibly have swum with
dolphins in a nameless pink sea between
Christmas and New Year's Eve because you
didn't leave Kansas and you have the
receipts to prove it
well one of Descartes contemporaries the
English philosopher Thomas Hobbes had
something to say about that what if
Descartes was performing his test in a
dream what if we ask an expert a
neuroscientist can measure the activity
in different parts of your brain and
tell you whether you're awake or
sleeping but that just brings us back to
the idea that any test you might use to
prove you're awake could take place in a
dream so far no one has found a
convincing response to this but let's be
real there's a whole lot more detail in
our waking experience than in dreams we
go to sleep and wake up again day after
day for many years and each day is full
of countless people places things
experiences even our memories which
capture just a fraction of this
experience contain an almost
incomprehensibly vast amount of detail
we can recall a line from a favorite
book decades later remember the musty
smell of its pages and the taste of a
lemonade we drank by while reading it
remember a dream we had about it and
tell someone all this isn't it
ridiculous to suggest a dream could ever
simulate this richness
well as the Persian philosopher
al-ghazali pointed out in the same way
we think we are now awake having woken
from dreams it is possible that we might
wake from our current state into another
state of even greater wakefulness which
would mean we're really in a kind of
dream state when we think we're awake
what philosophers really want to know is
what justifies our belief that we're
awake we all want to believe things
because we have reasons for them not
just because they seem right sometimes
the biggest challenge is to show why we
should believe something that seems
completely obvious to us all
enter the world of the immortal king of
dreams with Neil gaiman's Transcendent
series The Sandman narrated by a
star-studded cast this Saga will take
you beyond Earth to mythical lands
strange Realms and across the paths of
iconic figures download a free audiobook
version on audible.com Ted Dash Ed